si cette mission se présente comme une
mission de paie de médiation avec le but
de convaincre la Russie et l'Ukraine de
ce soir au table des pourparlers peu de
gens pensent que un tel résultat est
probable cela intervient au moment où
les Ukrainiens viennent tout juste
commencer leur contrefensif pour
reprendre les territoires en Ukraine
occupés par la Russie et juste après que
en toute probabilité la Russie a fait
exploser un barrage à carrouska
provoquant la pire catastrophe
écologique en Ukraine depuis Tchernobyl
est vraiment une catastrophe à l'échelle
mondiale c'est peu dire que de dire que
le moment n'est pas vraiment propice
mais il y a aussi urgent surtout du
point de vue de l'Afrique d'améliorer la
situation avec les exportations de
grains depuis l'Ukraine l'accord pour
les exportations de grains est en train
de fonctionner au compte-gout au mieux
les Ukrainiens se plaignent que les
Russes ne respecte pas les termes de
l'accord et ne laisse pas passer les
navires ne laisse pas rentrer les
navires dans les ports Ukrainiens pour
récupérer du grain pour l'exportation et
la Russie de la voix de Vladimir Poutine
se plaint que
la partie de l'Occident de cet accord en
termes de assouplissement de quelques
fonctions contre les banques russes et
leur accès au système Swift et facilité
les exportations de
produits nécessaires pour pour
l'agriculture russe n'est pas respecté
et menace donc de se retirer de cet
accord dont le terme d'expiration et le
17 juillet donc ils vont probablement
plus par les de ça et de comment
s'assurer que l'exportation des produits
agricoles ukrainiens et russes vers
l'Afrique peut s'augmenter
Gulliver bonjour les combats se
poursuivent où en est la
contre-offensive ukrainienne
alors les Ukrainiens officiellement ont
une politique de silence quant à leur
contrefosie mais Aurélie réalité il y a
des communications tous les jours et
vous avez la vis ministre de la Défense
en Amalia qui dit maintenant depuis
plusieurs jours que les forces
ukrainiennes avancent sur plusieurs fois
il semblerait qu'il y a trois axes
principaux où ils essayent d'avancer ils
avaient quelques centaines de mètres
vraiment pas très rapidement ils n'ont
pas encore fait de brèches dans les plus
grandes lignes de défense russe mais il
y a tous les jours aussi des frappes à
longues distances sur des positions
russes de l'autre côté de la lignée de
défense notamment sur des villes
relativement grandes dans le territoire
occupé de la région des aborigènes ont
perdu entre melithopole par exemple les
Ukrainiens disent ciblés des bases
russes des endroits où il y a de
l'équipement militaire qui s'est
stockés et avec un certain succès dans
ce sens là les font l'autre chose à
l'inverse aussi bien sûr et c'est pour
cela qu'il y a des frappes parfois sur
des villes en Ukraine là les Ukrainiens
ont même admis que les dernières frappes
à crier ont touché une entreprise
industrielle faisons un blessé mais pas
de mort ça c'est écrit dans le centre du
pays il faut croire que c'est ainsi que
soit réellement un cycle militaire avec
de l'équipement les rustices que c'est
une usine de drone ou bien c'est un
endroit que les Russes avaient pris pour
un tel cible donc il y a cette guerre de
tir à longue distance aussi qui va
peut-être être tout aussi déterminant
pour l'avenir de cette contre-offensive
que l'action avec les temps que et les
soldats sur le terrain